si vous voulez moi je ne veux pas
commenter au delà du strict nécessaire
cette affaire qui est en cours mais je
reprendrai ce que j'ai eu l'occasion de
dire si les faire réellement sont avérés
effectivement c'est une affaire grave
très grave en termes de comportement des
tic pour un ministre de la justice
certains bien sûr et donc la logique
c'est que monsieur airways soit
poursuivie devant la cour de justice de
la revue mais que voulez vous le demande
et pour le respect de l'institution
j'imagine vous le souhaitez je n'ai pas
à le souhaiter ni à le demander les
procédures sont telles que effectivement
il est très probable que l'acompte
justice soirée black milk soit 6,6 alors
une question peut-être plus politisé et
est ce que vous estimez que thierry
solère lui n'a plus sa place aujourd'hui
dans le parti présidentiel qu'il a
rejoint la république en marche
non messieurs les mois je ne raisonne
pas de mon de ma position ministre de la
justice sur ces questions là j'observe
une situation je juge qu'elle est grave
et manifestement cela des incidences qui
sont extrêmement puissante je me dois de
réagir face bonne solution là mais je ne
veux pas me positionner sur ce sujet là
gérard dur mais vous le comprenez dans
l'opinion à cette affaire jette le doute
sur l'affirmation selon laquelle les
politiques se tiennent à distance des
dossiers sensibles vous même quel est
votre pratique en la matière si vous
voulez moi je pense là aussi une
occasion de préciser je pense pas qu'on
puisse inférées d'une affaire
particulière et singulière une règle
générale je dis que nous sommes dans un
système où il appartient au gouvernement
de conduire des politiques publiques et
notamment de définir la politique former
et d'être informé de dossiers sont
sévères cela il doit effectivement
pouvoir bénéficier de remonter des
parquets et que ses remontées elles
portent soit sur des affaires qui
s'attache à l'ordre public soit sur des
affaires qui concernent des questions
internationales sensibles je pense
airbus soit sur des affaires qui traite
de personnalité particulière bref ou des
affaires d'ailleurs sur la criminalité
financière par exemple qui font l'objet
d'une politique pénale précise selon des
remontée automatique ce sont des
remontées qui parviennent bien mais tu
vois la demande
non non ce sont des remontées qui
parviennent à la direction des affaires
criminelles et des grâces les parquets
on voit ces informations le la direction
des affaires criminelles ensuite saisi
mon cabinet le cabinet du garde des
sceaux des affaires les plus sensibles
et mon cabinet m'alerte le cas échéant
d'accord des affaires particulières mais
vous vous le sollicitez jamais de cela
ma formation ça vous a réussi très
honnête cela peut m'arriver
mais c'est d'une part franchement très
rare franchement très rares et seulement
seulement dans les situations qui sont
prévues par la circulaire de 2014 qui
listent ces cas et une fois vous avez
des informations vous vous interdisez
bien sûr au nom de l'éthique des grands
principes
certains comportements bien sûr les ces
informations - gens disposent
elle me serre est ensuite à conduire
cette politique pénale permettez moi
simplement de prendre un exemple non
nominatif mais lorsqu il y à des
informations qui nous parviennent sur
par exemple des questions de viol de
mineure évidemment ces informations ne
parviennent à partir d' affaire
singulière
ce sont ces affaire singulière qui me
permettront ensuite de dégager des
règles générales de politique pénale
est-ce que selon vous cette affaire où
aujourd'hui plaide pour une séparation
définitive entre la chancellerie et le
parquet entre le pouvoir politique et le
pouvoir judiciaire alors d'une part je
dirais de deux choses si vous me le
permettez d'une part au moment où nous
parlons je viens de vous
rires nous avons besoin d'informations
venant des parquets pour conduire et
construire la politique du gouvernement
qu'il s'agisse de la politique pénale ou
bien des politiques publiques pour
lesquels la justice est partie prenante
parce que il y avait deux aspects donc
nous avons besoin me semble utile de
remonter mais en même temps le président
de la république a annoncé une révision
constitutionnelle au sein de laquelle
nous allons encore renforcer
l'indépendance la justice pleine et
entière a dit le candidat en modifiant
le statut des membres du parquet est par
exemple en confiant le pouvoir
disciplinaire des membres du parquet et
un pouvoir renforcé pour leur nomination
au conseil ce faire il y aura bien une
réforme constitutionnelle donc mais sur
la nomination des magistrats que vous
nous confirmez